joining us now for reaction from
Minneapolis is Johnny and her le he's a
former national spokesperson for the FBI
and here in Washington is Joe digenova a
former US Attorney for Washington DC Joe
your reaction to the McCabe departure
and the media from the moment the story
broke on all the other cables in on NBC
CBS ABC tonight
it was Trump to blame well to blame his
McCabe and to blame his co me and
everybody else at the senior levels of
the FBI this is quite a disgraceful
moment for the bureau as someone who has
worked with the bureau for over 30 years
I'm truly saddened by the fall from
grace of everybody there but make no
mistake about it this was a plot to
exonerate Hillary Clinton illegally and
then if she lost the election who framed
Donald Trump with an illegal crime this
is the worst period in the history of
the bureau much worse than the late
Hoover period when they were spying on
domestic groups
this was the weaponization of the FBI
for political purposes by all the people
at the upper echelon of the bureau and I
think it's really time for people in the
other party who seemed to make nothing
but excuses for the senior people at the
bureau and the Department of Justice may
I say to kind of wake up and see that
what's coming now is a federal grand
jury and it's not going to be pretty
John
you represented the bureau and the
public domain and you were the
spokesperson for the bureau your
reaction to the day's developments and
the effort to blame Donald Trump for the
early retirement of the deputy director
well wendy mccabe had been talking for
some time that he was looking to go on
terminal leave and exit the bureau I
think that was hastened as a result of
the director just yesterday going to the
hill looking at the information that
went into this dossier but I will tell
you no president whether it's Trump
Obama or anyone else tells the FBI what
to do the FBI is independent they are
there for the people and to think for a
minute that a sitting president would be
able to push out a deputy director
that goes against everything the FBI has
stood for for the past hundred and nine
years yeah well you did you speak to
mccabe a few weeks ago i happen to be at
headquarters a couple of weeks ago and
chatted with him briefly and What did he
say
well we didn't talk about him possibly
leaving at that time he was in the
office while the director was out on
other business so essentially he's the
man in charge it perceived to be
business as usual however everybody in
the bureau knew that McCabe's days would
be running short because of the history
it was time for the bureau to move on
with a clean slate and get back to the
work that the FBI does alright and Joe I
mean he wanted to leave in the spring
the IG report is coming out in the
spring but it's a wild coincidence if
indeed the FBI director strolls up the
Capitol Hill on Sunday reads this very
short report four pages and then it just
so happens that Monday o McCabe's like
you know something I'd rather go skiing
in Breckenridge for the next two weeks
I'm not I'm not going to be doing well
this work any longer well according to
the New York Times in the latest
publications Christopher Rea was shocked
on Sunday when he read the four pages
now first of all if that's the case
where has he been since he was sworn in
there is enough evidence on the public
record before that with empathy with the
information from the Inspector General
and from the hill with the release legal
release of documents that it was clear
that mr. McCabe and others had engaged
in highly improper probably illegal
activity in the FISA Court stuff along
with the dossier from Christopher Steele
so first of all mccabe should have been
gone a long time ago and so should
struck and page and all the people
involved in this this is a dark moment
for the FBI it's going to take a lot for
them to recover from this we had Jim
Comey tweeting after the McCabe news
came out he sees tweeting quite a bit
very poetic
yes he said Special Agent Andrew McCabe
stood tall over the last eight months he
always makes height references oh man I
wonder why when small people were trying
to tear down an institution we all
depend on he served with distinction for
two decades I wish Andy well I also wish
continued strength for the rest of the
FBI America needs you John what do you
make of the Comey tweet well small
people I will tell you tall people he's
six foot eight by the way come in go
ahead
obviously McCabe is part of commis
legacy now andrew became well did a lot
of good things in the bureau during his
career but it doesn't matter when you're
doing something wrong that is the time
that it has to be stopped immediately
I had some very good agents that made an
unfortunate mistake along the way John
he was the guy to whom Peter struck
reported correct yeah that's that and
McCain could have Joe we're almost out
of time
McCabe could have used a just one of the
regular field office set of
investigators to do both the Clinton and
the Trump investigation these are
professionals who could run this thing
and run it right he chose to put
together this team correct code
unfortunate mistake Comey was a dirty
cop and unfortunately he dirtied up
everybody else around him